[Music]
all right he called his shot
he called his shot in grade school chase
young
future nfl player i think it should have
said future
nfl defensive rookie of the year
probably future defensive player of the
year
probably future super bowl mvp here he
is in the present chase young chase
great to see you buddy
great to see you guys too thanks for
having me how old were you in that
picture
i think i was in first grade
first grade i remember uh you know um
our teachers had told us to
to basically uh put what you wanted to
be when you grew up
um and they was going to put on our
names and uh
that's what i chose a lot of kids have
the dream at that age
when did you first know in your heart
it's going to be your reality
i would say uh the first time i i kind
of came face to face and kind of talked
about it a little bit
um and kind of knew it was college after
my freshman year even
um and going in my sophomore year uh
even the middle of my sophomore year in
college uh people just you know they
just started talking about the nfl
and things like that so uh definitely
college is is is when i knew that uh
that you know it was it was it was right
in front of me i'm shocked by that first
off because um i don't know just by the
way you look i think you might have
known by in eighth grade like
i want to follow up with that and go
when the hell did you know
you were a freak of nature and i mean
that respectfully i really do
of course but when did you know i'm a
different specimen
second grade of high school i i'd say is
when i kind of started to see my stress
i mean
in eighth grade um coming out of eighth
grade uh i was five six
i wasn't yeah i was small so uh
i think when i got to the ninth grade i
grew to about five eleven
and then my sophomore year i was about
six two and a half
six threes and i started uh you know
getting faster
uh arms getting longer um and i'm just
uh
you know just i'm i'm i'm falling in
with my body
and and just learning how to how to move
with it right like what like was it like
one of those things too where
were you like oh my gosh i can't get
over how much weight i can lift or like
i can dunk so easy like was there a
moment where you were just like holy cow
okay
i'm pretty amazing yeah i mean i i can
tell
you know just how my body matured um
even when i did play ball
um just getting up was so easy yeah
and just from the field i just felt more
i felt myself getting more explosive
um and and and just faster as
i matured um but it was definitely a
10th grade got the old spice jersey on
but on your football jersey they sewed
that c patch on during the season what
did that mean for you
to have that captain added to your to
your role with the team
um it was uh it was crazy um when it
happened
um it was right before uh the the
panthers game um i was walking into the
locker room and uh
you know just like a you know an another
game day and uh
i went to eq um and i asked them
something
uh i forgot and they had told me they
said chase gotta go you gotta go look on
your uh
go go go go back and look on your jersey
so i went back in there
i looked in my jersey it was a c i said
oh
i said okay so immediately i ran right
into a coach revere office
um and i just thank him uh because um
you know even being a rookie
um getting that type of respect um you
know from my coaches and my team
is it just means a lot and it's just
something that you can't put in words
and i get the impression that you're
obviously by the example you set but
you seem like you're willing to embrace
and able to embrace that responsibility
important responsibility of leading by
telling the guys getting the guys going
firing them up and getting them in that
right mindset
yeah i mean i it's something that i've
been doing since high school
um just being a being vocal um
so it was it was something uh when i
came on a team and
you know i was just uh i was just being
loud everywhere and being energized with
bunny that's that's just me
um i did it in high school um i did it
in college you can actually you know any
coach who coached me
um that's just how i am and uh and
and and you know it wasn't you know you
know it wasn't
on my list of you know i i want to be
capping my my work here to
it it didn't go like that it was just
something that happened and uh some that
i'm just blessed to be
that ohio state culture i mean i'm
fascinated by it
you just you got ballers all over the
place first three picks of the draft
last year you're all in the same damn
college locker room
nick bowser the year before like what
did that do to you
as a player you know as far as raising
your own game
yeah com it was it was it's just crazy
the the things that we did at ohio state
um how competitive
we had to be um the situations they
would put us in in practice
um spring ball you know every day you
know
you was going at it you know with no
game so it was very practical
bang for real um and you know we'll have
a you know competitive days uh certain
types of days of the week
um in those days i mean you know coach
johnson i know in our room
uh he'll tally up your wins and your
losses um and you know
you don't want to you you didn't want to
lose you know you know i'm thankful i
had a
you know a great player like nick in
front of me um nick was those guys who
you know it was a day he he might have
never lost a
a record uh you know in one-on-ones or
you know
um it was if it was a pass rush and we
had five plays um you know he was a guy
who might have got a sack on all five
plays so
um you know that was something me coming
up i was just looking to do and
something that uh you know i did achieve
um in practice and stuff like that but
just stuff like that um you know
it definitely uh brings the best out of
the guys
um yeah i mean i'm i'm amazed by that
i mean first off both of you and nick
bose are built like greek gods you're
both got maybe the quickest step off the
ball like
tell me about that personal you know
competition
between him every day did you guys
compete in everything sprints weight
room all of that stuff
yeah so it wasn't even really competing
but like uh say if
we had like a mat drills and we had
these certain drills these bag drills
they would pair you up um with somebody
else mission
but they would count wins and losses so
it's like uh you're not caring who it is
you i don't want to lose
you know but it's like those in and and
out there you know
you'll be dying you know saying it and
you still you know still be competing
so what uh it really i think when it
when
when competing pushes you to the edge
like that and somebody like nick
uh you know who's not gonna stop um and
somebody like myself who knocked on the
side
um i feel like it just brings the best
out of uh both of us
um and this and i feel like drills like
that definitely helped me um you know
throughout my career and just in the
game
chase you saw the buccaneers up close in
the wild card round of the playoffs what
stood out to you the most about their
offense
um i would say uh
just how their their running game i mean
they they're
their offense who who has all the all
the tools i would say
um that they can pass the ball they can
run the ball um
they have to have a good uh offensive
line um so i feel like it's the offense
who who can do it all
and uh you know um you got you got to go
back there and he's the best at uh you
know obviously managing games and
and keeping his his self in the game so
uh
it's definitely gonna be uh exciting to
watch
and i saw the picture of the jersey that
tom brady sent you after that game
how tempted were you to cross out go
blue before you put it in a frame
and i saw a girl you know i never lost
to that team so
[Laughter]
go away blue i love it yeah yeah you own
jim harbaugh in the michigan wolverines
i'm all for that
i i do want to have a little fun with
you before we get into your old spice
all right and all that
um uh you know man
you are you're some mama's boy i'll tell
you i want to know about that
mama being in all the face time
post-game press conferences like just
tell us about mom and how that kind of
happens yeah
uh you know um you know when i was uh
i don't know what i was young um uh
adolescent
uh probably even younger uh you know i
always told my mom the first thing i
told my mom
was that uh she wouldn't have to pay for
college uh when i was young and then
i told her that i was gonna be a first
round pick you know just watching the
drafts um
you know just just every year as i got
older so
it was something always in the back of
my head um
that you know i was i was always kind of
doing it for my mom
uh and just really trying to prove
to her that uh you know i that i'm not a
liar that uh
everything that i said i want to do and
i told you i was gonna do that i did
and uh that's basically uh that's
basically
what it would that that's basically one
of my motivation
uh mechanisms um
just with everything yeah um even
defensive work of the year um
um god willing if if if if i
take that home during the honors uh you
know that was something that uh
last year um during this time that i
told people that uh you know i was gonna
win uh that i would i was gonna speak
into existence
um and now i'm just blessed to hear my
name uh
just to be involved with that uh
prestigious award
well chase you got something else you
can tell your mom and you can
deliver on it you can say mom i'm not
gonna stink up the house anymore
because i got old spice tell us more
about old spice
yeah so you know obviously um it's it's
it's it's been a tough year um
for everyone uh you know even some
players this year might have been a
little down
uh you know just dealing um with the uh
scheduling
and things like that just because it's
totally different um but old spice
is is coming out there a new line uh and
it's called dynasty
um and and it's something that can give
you that uh that real burst
burst of confidence um just just the
smell ready for anything
um i just put some on uh it's real
strong and it smells pretty good
all right hey chase uh you're looking
pretty good in that shirt matches your
team colors which makes it even better
congratulations on your success
congratulations in advance on being
defensive rookie of the year i got a
feeling you're going to win it and all
the best going forward
thank you thank you good luck man way to
go i'm gonna go
see ya hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports